hundreds of uniformed and plain clothes
police officers are out in force in
tiananmen square backed up by military
police
their mission to prevent anyone from
marking the anniversary of the crackdown
many ordinary chinese are afraid to even
talk to journalists
no
i don't know
well
hong kong is the only exception since it
was returned by britain to china in 1997
it has remained a special administrative
region and enjoys more freedom than the
mainland
people here can publicly mourn the
hundreds killed in the massacre a
quarter of a century ago
tiananmen square in the early hours of
june 4th 1989.
tanks rolled onto the square shooting
dead hundreds possibly thousands of
students
it was a brutal crackdown after six
weeks of protests calling for democratic
reforms
images like these are banned in china
and websites that show them are blocked
many of those involved in the
demonstrations went into exile like wu
arkaishi who now lives in
i've now spent more of my life in exile
than in china
most chinese have seen a major
improvement in their living standards
over the past 25 years the economy has
grown rapidly but hopes for political
reform remain unfulfilled
you